you can see why they come to the
highlands to escape and after a platinum
jubilee health worries and family
troubles some would say this year the
queen deserves the break
the locals in ballard certainly don't
give her any bother they just see her as
one of them
there we go the queen's coronation visit
to scotland she came to bryn's bookshop
after floods in 2015. i think there's
some degree of
protectiveness and i think basically
they they welcome the queen coming here
for a number of reasons really and and i
think she's always been part of the
family as it were
the queen may come here for peace and
tranquility but for staff at the palace
summit is often anything but quiet as
they're all busy prepping for
engagements to start again in the autumn
what is likely to make it more tricky
this year is what we're all having to
get used to which is the queen doing a
lot less and others having to step in
it's meant more responsibility for
prince charles and prince william who've
both had successes and problems charles
with his charities william with that
caribbean tour both will start the
autumn term with new communications
secretaries we wait to see if pr
strategies change
my sense from talking to people at the
palace both on
the queen's side and the prince of wales
society and prince william
is that the the households are working
very closely together perhaps more
closely than ever
that the the the need to have a smoother
transition as possible
so that the burden doesn't land too much
on the prince of wales or prince william
but some believe after the events of the
past year there needs to be more public
discussion about the future journalist
polly toymbi is part of a group called
the commission on political power
encouraging debate on constitutional
issues including the monarchy i don't
think anybody's thinking of removing the
queen from her position it's more a
question of make her elizabeth the last
do we want another one after her there's
certainly much less popularity for those
who coming after her throughout the year
the palace have kept stressing just how
much she still does behind the scenes
and the summer will be the same her
break already guaranteed to be cut short
in some way to welcome a new prime
minister in september rhiannon mills sky
news in ballard